IT'S TIME TO PLAY FLIGHT RISKS.
FLIGHT RISKS. NOW...
(WHOOPING, CHEERING)
MODERN AIR TRAVEL IS BOTH FAST
AND CONVENIENT, UH, IN CASE YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT FLYING
BEFORE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT'S PLAGUED
WITH SUBHUMAN PASSENGERS.
FORTUNATELY, THERE'S A POPULAR
ONLINE TREND KNOWN AS
"PASSENGER SHAMING," AND IT IS
COMPLETELY NECESSARY.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A PICTURE OF
AN INCONSIDERATE TRAVELER, AND
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME THE REASON YOU THINK
THEY'RE FLYING.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST ONE.
WHAT ABOUT THIS HERE?
>> UH, I THINK HE'S FLYING TO
MEET ANDY DICK IN AN AIRPORT
BATHROOM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
NICK.
>> UM, HE'S FLYING TO THE
OPENING OF A NEW CINNABON.
(LAUGHTER)
AND BY THE WAY...
BY THE WAY, HE'S...
HE'S DEFINITELY FLYING VIRGIN.
>> OH! OH!
>> OH!
(WHOOPING, WHISTLING, APPLAUSE)
>> HARDWICK: CHRIS.
>> THAT'S AQUAMAN COMING BACK
FROM VACATION.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: OH! OH, MY GOD,
TOTALLY!
YES.
POINTS.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE.
THIS BOOZE HOUND, THIS BOOZE
HOUND.
WHAT IS HE...
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> HE IS, UH, HE IS FLYING TO
MEET ME FOR A TINDER DATE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
DID...
DID YOU GUYS... DID YOU GUYS SEE
THE SADDEST LITTLE EASTER EGG
RIGHT HERE?
AW.
(CHUCKLES)
>> THAT'S MY DAUGHTER.
>> HARDWICK: UH, COULD BE.
>> UH, THAT'S THE PILOT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> YES.
>> HARDWICK: LAST ONE-- THIS
DIRTY HEAD SEAWEED.
WHAT IS THAT, UH...
WHAT IS THAT, CHRIS?
>> UH, I'M JUST SURPRISED THAT
KATHY GRIFFIN IS FLYING COACH.